voilà donc merci à tous les deux de
votre présence monsieur le ministre
Madame la Directrice donc nous
poursuivons nos travaux sur de la
commission d'enquête sur l'efficacité
des politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique avec votre
audition monsieur le ministre qui
s'inscrit dans la série d'auditions
d'anciens ministres par laquelle nous
avons débuté nos travaux et qui
s'achèvera pour la série des anciens
ministres la semaine prochaine avec la
dernière audition celle de Julien de
Normandie en effet il nous semble à la
fois utile de bénéficier de vos retours
d'expérience et il est de la
responsabilité des ministres de répondre
de leur action devant le Parlement c'est
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui en
répondant à la convocation de notre
commission d'enquête monsieur le
ministre vous avez été de mai 2017 à
septembre 2018 ministre d'État en charge
de la transition écologique et solidaire
vous êtes accompagné ce soir de Madame
Michel papelardeau qui a été alors votre
directrice de cabinet madame je précise
que vous avez également été auparavant
présidente de l'Agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie l'ADEME et commissaire général
au développement durable puis présidente
de chambre et rapporteur général du
rapport public et des programmes à la
Cour des comptes monsieur le ministre 10
juillet 2017 vous avez présenté un plan
climat ambitieux suivi en avril 2018
d'un plan d'aide à la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments dont
l'objectif de 500 000 logements rénovés
par an visé précisément à massifier et à
accélérer la dynamique des travaux en
mobilisant 14 milliards d'euros sur 5
ans
qu'est devenu le plan de rénovation que
vous aviez lancé a-t-il été victime de
votre départ et de l'obligation pour un
ministre de faire des annonces plutôt
que d'appliquer des décisions de son
prédécesseur avec le recul qui est le
vôtre aujourd'hui quel bilan tirez-vous
de cette expérience gouvernementale lors
de votre départ du gouvernement vous
aviez dénoncé la présence excessive des
lobbys dans la décision publique et
teste le cas en matière de rénovation
énergétique avez-vous
identifié d'autres difficultés qui vous
aurez empêché d'aller aussi loin et
aussi vite que vous le souhaitiez vous
n'exerciez pas la tutelle du ministère
du logement était pour vous un handicap
pour mener à bien la politique que vous
souhaitiez aujourd'hui le bâtiment
demeure un secteur particulièrement
énergivore et émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre les objectifs de rénovation
énergétique que nous nous étions fixés
notamment la rénovation de 500 000
logements par an ne sont pas atteints
les résultats contrastent donc avec les
ambitions assignées il nous sera donc
intéressant que avec votre expérience
vous puissiez nous partager votre
jugement de la politique menée depuis
votre départ du gouvernement la
rénovation énergétique bute-t-elle sur
des questions de financement de
réglementation de méthode
d'inconstances ou sur une prise de
conscience insuffisante des enjeux
avant de vous laisser la parole pour un
propos introductif d'une quinzaine de
minutes il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'un compte rendu
sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc tous les deux à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je le jure
je le jure
voilà je vous remercie tous les deux je
vais vous laisser maintenant la parole
et puis ensuite notre rapporteur et les
membres de notre commission d'enquête
qui sont présents dans cette salle
pourront également vous poser un certain
nombre de questions
merci madame la Présidente
au préalable durant 15 minutes ou moins
juste d'abord une petite remarque
si jamais au cours de cette audition la
mémoire défaille un peu c'est pour ça je
suis content Michel sois là parce que
depuis deux ans j'ai un petit peu pris
de distance avec ce sujet là qui est un
sujet complexe mais sachant m'avait
prévenu à l'avant j'ai pu quand même
essayer
de réviser un certain nombre un certain
nombre de choses
plutôt qu'un bilan
qui serait très vite fait en ce qui
concerne mon passage au ministère
je vous propose peut-être un
enseignement
parce que
j'ai gardé de cette ce passage au
ministère
réflexion
qui n'apporte pas forcément toutes les
réponses mais qui est je dirais commune
à toutes ces politiques publiques qui
parfois échouent ou à chope et sur
lequel on aurait peut-être tendance un
peu facilement essayer de trouver un ou
une coupable
et peut-être que la raison d'être de
l'échec ou l'insuffisance ou de la
lenteur
de ces objectifs et ses politiques
publiques elle est plus complexe que
cela
je dis ça parce que dans le domaine de
l'écologie au sens large du terme
combien ai-je vu d'objectifs de plan
d'engagement
fixé parfois dans la loi
pas simplement dans la rénovation
énergétique pas simplement dans la
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre y compris par exemple je prends un
exemple parmi d'autres qui me vient à
l'esprit la réduction de l'utilisation
des pesticides on se fixe un objectif
ambitieux et puis quand on arrive au
terme de cet objectif on s'aperçoit que
non seulement on l'a pas atteint au
contraire qu'il n'a fait que
l'utilisation n'a fait qu'augmenter mais
que s'est-il passé la question qu'on
peut se poser entre les deux qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé entre le moment on a
posé sur la table un objectif et le
moment où on prend acte pour finir il a
à chopé
et je pense que la réponse elle est
encore une fois je le dis parce qu'on a
tendance à simplifier et pour moi c'est
un vrai sujet de démocratie pour
redonner confiance aussi à la politique
parce que les citoyennes et citoyens se
rendent compte que les années passent et
que pour finir les difficultés parfois
perdues
simplement volonté des politiques je ne
crois pas est-ce que c'est l'alternance
politique qui fait que quand il y a un
changement de gouvernement on oublie les
engagements
ça n'est pas aussi simple que cela et je
dirais d'ailleurs par rapport aux
arguments que vous avez donné c'est
peut-être même l'ensemble de ces
arguments il y va de la complexité bien
entendu il est voit parfois de la
disparité entre les moyens envisagés et
les moyens
affichés mais je dirais que ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé
et je le dis avec beaucoup de prudence
parce que je ne veux rêver que ces
personnes mais c'est le manque de
méthode
le manque de méthode de stratégie
surtout pour des objectifs qui sont sur
le temps long
et qui parfois
comment dire entraîne des mutations qui
sont profondes
parce que
vous sénatrice et sénateurs
aux collègues députés parfois pouvaient
prendre une disposition qui est
applicable immédiatement mais là on
parle de métamorphose de mutation qui
sont très lourdes
la rénovation
thermique c'est un peu la clé de voûte
de la mutation la transition énergétique
et pendant des années
la préoccupation des uns et des autres
n'étaient pas de réduire la consommation
c'était simplement de donner accès à
l'électricité au plus grand nombre
d'abord parce que nous n'avions pas
l'impératif climatique et puis parce que
nous avons peut-être vécu avec
l'illusion d'une énergie bon marché
donc
moi ce qui m'a frappé dans beaucoup de
domaines
quand je vois par exemple pour revenir à
votre sujet
entre le Grenelle de l'environnement
la loi de transition
énergétique et de croissance verte le
Plan Climat
j'en ai noté la stratégie bas carbone
et d'autres lois qui ont suivi mon
propre passage
simplement de dire que c'est un manque
de volonté que c'est simplement pour
tromper les apparences
je crois que c'est un peu simple parce
que chacun rêverait de pouvoir avoir à
son crédit une réalisation efficace et
de dire voyez nous avons divisé par
temps la consommation d'énergie nous
avons
éradiqué puisque c'est le mot qu'on
employait tous voilà donc je pense de
temps en temps d'ailleurs au passage que
les mots nous avons les yeux plus gros
que le ventre voilà mais voilà cette
méthode parce que dans ces
transformations là et notamment
dans la transition énergétique que nous
impose à la fois à certains nombre de
paramètres sur la rareté de l'énergie
mais aussi
l'enjeu climatique qui est venu se
greffer aux autres enjeux récemment
moi je pense que dans alors ça va vous
paraître un peu simpliste
mais il faut mettre en œuvre quatre
principes
le premier principe c'est un principe de
prévisibilité
en fonction évidemment des impératifs
scientifiques aussi ou parfois sociaux
mais le climat prime donc nous avons un
engagement de réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui ont été pris à
la COP 21 ça n'est pas rien puisque nous
sortons d'une société tout carbone
j'allais dire
donc oui il faut se fixer un objectif si
possible en accord avec les impératifs
de la science
mais en tenant compte évidemment la
difficulté de l'exercice très bien dire
on sort des véhicules thermiques demain
matin pour faire plaisir
derrière la présidité je mettrai un
deuxième principe c'est la progressivité
la progressivité parce que il faut
laisser personne sur le carreau
quand je j'ai pris ce ministère
c'est peut-être très symbolique mais
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai voulu rajouter
le mot solidaire à la transition
écologique et solidaire parce que
j'avais conscience qu'on pouvait pas
imposer un certain nombre de choses et
surtout quand on changeait de pied dans
certains nombre de politiques quand tout
d'un coup le diesel qui était jusqu'à
présent supporté avec une fiscalité
incitative tout d'un coup on allait le
basculer dans l'autre sens donc oui il
fallait cette progressivité évidemment
accompagner des moyens des évaluations
pour permettre notamment à ceux qui
subissaient cette transformation cette
mutation de pouvoir le faire ou
d'anticiper s'il y avait un changement
de métier s'il y avait un changement de
comportement un changement de véhicule
un changement de
le troisième principe c'est pour moi un
principe d'irréversibilité
parce que et ça vaut notamment dans le
domaine qui qui le vôtre
il y a un moment de changer en
permanence
de méthode de recettes de moyens
vous parliez de massification tout à
l'heure
si on veut un moment un autre que tous
les acteurs s'engagent y compris sont un
plan industriel
ça veut pas dire que parfois il faut
quelques faut pas quelques corrections
bien entendu quelques adaptations mais
en tout cas il faut être sûr que
l'objectif il est cranté et qu'il y aura
pas de retour en arrière quelle que soit
les alternances politiques comment on le
fait-on je ne sais pas mais pour moi
c'est très important et le quatrième je
veux pas être trop long pardon
c'est la visibilité quand je dis de la
visibilité c'est le suivi c'est à dire
qu'on sache d'année en année où on en
est voilà on prend des objectifs de zéro
artificialisation des sols ça me vient
comme ça à l'esprit ok d'accord mais il
faudrait que dans chaque mairie on fasse
un point zéro puis à partir de là on
regarde les choses mais c'est un c'est
pas une critique facile que je fais
parce que en vous apportant cet
éclairage vous apporte pas forcément les
solutions mais
il y a un intrus dans notre logiciel
démocratique c'est le temps long
et le tendon se gère pas comme le temps
court et donc oui il faut de la méthode
oui il faut des outils d'évaluation
et puis je dirais aussi
je vais plus l'observer un tout petit
peu quand même pendant mon bref passage
il faut que les moyens qui sont mis en
œuvre
soit adaptés aux objectifs
j'ai trop vu de promesses
avec une forme de sincérité mais dont on
savait où je pouvais pressentir que je
n'en au que je n'aurais pas les moyens
sauf à une révision budgétaire de les
tenir et donc il faut hiérarchiser aussi
les priorités
je
peux prendre un exemple récent parce que
je suis pas là pour juger les décisions
qui sont pris mais c'est pour donner un
ordre d'exemple
le gouvernement dans la hausse du prix
de l'énergie récemment
a pris une mesure je crois que c'est
[Musique]
5 milliards d'euros pour mettre en place
le bouquet tarifaire
bon mais sur ce sujet qui est le vôtre
et notamment pour accompagner les
dispositifs qui sont des en place on en
met 18 fois moins donc voilà moi je
pense et je vais en terminer
votre sujet et c'est pas pour vous
flatter mais c'est un sujet central
pourquoi parce que et ça c'est ma
conviction profonde
toute politique énergétique quel que
soit ce que
l'exécutif et législatif vont décider
elle est conditionnée par la sobriété et
l'efficacité énergétique
vous pouvez mettre du tout nucléaire si
vous dit ou du tout
renouvelable
et d'ailleurs cet objectif est inscrit
dans la loi je le rappelle parce qu'il
me semble qu'on l'a on l'a oublié et
donc l'efficacité énergétique et
notamment dans le bâtiment parce que
c'est là que
la plus grande source d'économie donc
c'est prioritaire ces prioritaires parce
que voilà souvent on a opposé écologie
et sociale là je vais vous dire
effectivement c'est une mesure sociale
parce que on découvre pas vous mais on a
découvert un peu tard la précarité
énergétique elle est de pire en pire
notamment avec cette envolée des prix
et
troisièmement on sait que le bâtiment
rentre pour
on est 44% dans la consommation
d'énergie primaire et 27% dans la
production des gaz à effet de serre donc
on est vraiment
au cœur d'une problématique à sa raison
d'être et sur lequel à mon avis il faut
pas baisser la garde au contraire et
puis je dirais que sur un plan purement
économique et j'en terminerai là-dessus
pardon si j'ai oublié de répondre à
quelques questions mais si elle vous
m'avez posé une question sur les lobbies
je dirais un tout petit mot
il y va aussi de notre balance
commerciale c'est-à-dire que toute
l'énergie enfin n'oublions pas demain je
vais à l'Assemblée pour une commission
sur la souveraineté énergétique
me semble-t-il que nous sommes dans la
consommation énergétique je parle pas de
la consommation électrique dépendant du
gaz russe pour certains
[Musique]
du Moyen-Orient pour le pétrole de
certains pays comme le Kazakhstan pour
l'uranium donc tout ce qu'on peut éviter
de consommer ou produire en interne
c'est bon pour la balance et tous les
métiers qui sont liés à votre
préoccupation sont des métiers qui sont
pas des localisables donc c'est c'est
pour employer une expression de
publicitaires c'est gagnant-gagnant sur
toute la
juge termine sur une chose n'hésitez pas
à me relancer si j'ai oublié quelque
chose non madame
s'il y a un domaine où j'ai pas souffert
des lobbies c'est celui-là enfin en tout
cas pas voilà
je
veux pas mettre ça sur le sur le sur le
tapis il y a des domaines qui sont plus
compliqués à gérer
je peux pas ce que je veux peut-être
simplement dire c'est que je pense que
ça n'a pas été immédiatement l'intérêt
de DF
je parle pas récemment mais de réduire
sa consommation le métier premier de DF
pour nous très longtemps c'était de
vendre de l'électricité et on peut le
comprendre et peut-être un peu de retard
à l'image pour que le métier se double
de cette vocation qui est aussi de faire
de l'efficacité énergétique ça peut
expliquer aussi un certain nombre de de
retard voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
j'espère donc si j'étais un peu long
pas du tout monsieur le ministre est-ce
que Madame papa voulait rajouter quelque
chose
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
donc je vais essayer de compléter
peut-être si nécessaire au fur et à
mesure mais j'ai pas de déclaration
préliminaire à faire merci alors merci
je laisse la parole à notre rapporteur
merci merci Monsieur le mésisme Madame
la directrice de cabinet
moi j'avais quelques quelques questions
effectivement et peut-être rebondir sur
sur la fin c'est vrai que sur la
question de la rénovation thermique ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est quelque
chose et plusieurs ministres d'ailleurs
nous l'ont dit c'est quelque chose qui
fait consensus et politiquement vous
connais personne qui va dire qu'il faut
pas agir sur ce sur cet aspect là comme
vous l'avez dit c'est vrai que sur la
question des lobbys c'est pas forcément
là où on va dire qu'elle a le plus de le
plus de pression donc on pourrait se
dire qu'on est sur un sujet assez facile
c'est simple à mettre en oeuvre qu'on a
des objectifs et c'est vrai que si on
reprend le Grenelle de le Grenelle de
l'environnement où on avait déjà des
orientations des objectifs qui étaient
qui étaient très forts et c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque en tant que représentant
d'une du ONG vous aviez à la fois un
petit peu regretté justement qu'on
n'aille pas qu'on aille pas assez loin
mais en tout cas déjà à cette époque là
on avait des orientations qui étaient
assez et pourtant on n'y arrive pas en
tout cas on n'atteint pas ces objectifs
là et on a l'impression que on remet en
fait des politiques publiques comme ça
un petit peu par couche successivement
donc je voulais avoir un peut-être un
peu plus précisément votre avis en comme
vous avez été justement en
responsabilité vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de
ça et puis peut-être revenir sur donc
quand vous êtes arrivé en 2018
donc on a reçu la semaine dernière je
sais plus ou 15 jours je sais plus mais
c'était Ségolène Royal
et c'est vrai qu'il bon nous expliquer
ce qu'elle avait pu mettre en place avec
le cite avec tapsv en lien justement
avec avec les collectivités
ce qu'elle avait pu obtenir aussi en
termes financier en tout cas pour
justement aller vers la rénovation
rénovation thermique on va dire qu'elle
était un petit peu voilà de dire bah en
fait on a tout balayé derrière et en
fait ça n'a pas tenu et justement il y a
eu ce manque de poursuite de continuité
et donc je voulais savoir en fait
peut-être justement en ayant en étant
arrivé après justement ces dispositifs
là qu'est-ce qui fait que on les a
changé qu'on les a modifié les raisons
en tout cas qui ont fait qu'on ait pu
qu'on ait pu modifier ses dispositifs
l'autre aspect qui va aussi avec sur les
différents ministres qu'on a pu qu'on a
pu rencontrer sur le fait que vous avez
été un ministre un ministre d'État mais
vous ayez pas la tutelle du ministre du
ministère du Logement
savoir si ça c'est quelque chose c'est
vrai qu'on a eu pas mal de retours aussi
de vos collègues qui disaient que
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui leur
paraissait qui leur paraissait important
et peut-être justement votre votre
dialogue en tout cas ou non dialogue je
sais pas en tout cas mais le lien avec
le ministère du logement qui me paraît
aussi
qui me paraît aussi important et puis
peut-être pour laisser de la place aussi
aux questions à mes à mes collègues sur
peut-être quelques quelques questions
plus plus précises à la fois sur je
crois que c'était à l'époque justement
du Grenelle
vous êtes une des propositions donc
c'était en 2010 qui était de rendre
obligatoire la rénovation d'un logement
quand il est vendu et ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous est revenu je crois que
c'est François de Rugy qu'on a parlé
aussi et peut-être pourquoi justement ce
dispositif qui avait été imaginé très
tôt et on a parlé et aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas en place alors on est parti
sur autre chose avec l'interdiction de
location des passoires thermiques mais
selon vous justement pourquoi c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas été qui n'a
pas été mis en oeuvre en tout cas qui
qui n'est pas aujourd'hui en place et
puis pour terminer puisque
par rapport à tout ce que vous avez pu
dire et sur la question de la visibilité
il y a quand même la question aussi
financière et de et du budget qu'on peut
avoir à la fois du budget dans la dans
la durée et on a posé la question aux
différents ministres Emmanuel wargon
nous disait que par rapport à ce qui est
actuellement il manquerait un milliard
d'euros en tout cas sur la rénovation
globale c'était peut-être là qu'il
fallait réellement agir sur une
revanovation performante et donc elle a
annoncé le chiffre d'un milliard d'euros
est-ce que vous selon vos enfin voilà
quand vous étiez en
poste et par rapport à votre expérience
voilà en termes de finances et de ce qui
ce qui est le budget vous vous penseriez
intéressant en tout cas de mettre et
suivant les dispositifs qu'on pourrait
qu'on pourrait imaginer voilà merci
merci
n'hésitez pas si comme il y avait
beaucoup de choses pas noté au fur et à
mesure pour bien vous écouter mais
quand on est arrivé
au ministère
il y avait l'annonce du grand plan
d'investissement
57 milliards d'euros me semble-t-il
à l'époque et il y en avait pour notre
ministère je crois annoncé 30 milliards
quelque chose comme ça
et il devait y avoir 9 milliards pour
l'efficacité énergétique notamment fait
chez les ménages les propriétaires ou
les locataires les plus modestes
pour dire les choses aussi voilà
je suis toujours demandé où était passé
cet argent je suis pas en train de
soupçonner la moindre voilà mais que
c'est des sommes quand même conséquentes
et dans le même temps à chaque fois
qu'on avait une réunion en terminale à
Matignon
fallait qu'on
discute on discute pour obtenir un
certain nombre de choses et tout était
toujours plutôt combien de fois j'ai
entendu le mot rabot un peu au rabot
je donnerai des exemples tout à l'heure
et notamment par rapport à ce que disait
la ministre Ségolène Royal parce que
contrairement peut-être à ce qu'elle
pense penser
ce qu'elle avait mis en place sur les
territoires
énergie positive et de croissance verte
quand on est arrivé au ministère
elle avait
engagé
sur ce sur l'enveloppe spéciale pour la
transition énergétique
750 millions d'euros
et nous nous sommes aperçus que
elle n'avait obtenu que 400 millions
d'euros
de
crédits budgétaires
donc il y avait un déficit de 350
millions d'euros
et la tendance était de mettre fin à
cela compte tenu de cela et je le dis
très sincèrement on s'est beaucoup battu
parce que c'était des engagements pris
avec les collectivités
et nous avons au contraire nous ne
sommes battus pour que les engagements
pris en dépit de cela soit tenu
et comme donc pour finir il y a quelques
projets qui entre-temps c'était arrêté
mais globalement toutes les promesses
ont pu être tenues et je dirais que
Michel et moi nous nous sommes beaucoup
investis auprès de Matignon pour que
cette promesse soit tenue voilà mais
nous avons découvert ce cela à l'époque
oui
dans le même temps
pour vous donner un exemple de un peu
parfois le l'état d'esprit un peu
contradictoire
quand on a modifié enfin on a proposé de
modifier le crédit d'impôts notamment
dans le loi de finance qui était en
2018 parce que paraît-il moi j'ai écouté
les experts les études démontrer qu'il
était beaucoup trop généreux par rapport
à l'efficacité étonné parce que je
pensais que les portes et les fenêtres
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire en premier
mais là on venait m'expliquer qu'il
fallait faire les combles les isolation
par l'extérieur bon voilà
en revanche je me suis plié puisque
l'idée c'était de faire des choses qui
étaient plus efficaces mais ce que je
trouvais que la suppression qui était
prévue initialement était trop
systématique et surtout trop rapide
et puis surtout j'essaie de retrouver
les chiffres
on voulait
[Musique]
des opérations du cite ce qui n'était
pas la proposition initiale finalement
quand on regarde l'évolution des choses
entre
les discussions qu'il y a eu après entre
la suite des gilets jaunes et le plan de
relance on est revenu finalement au 2
milliards qu'on avait initialement mais
voilà ça fait partie des un peu des
allers-retours et des problèmes de temps
en temps de visibilité qu'on peut avoir
sur ces politiques parce que c'est pas
forcément très compréhensible pour pour
le grand public de voir ses
allers-retours même si derrière il y
avait une bonne raison j'ai retrouvé
pardon merci merci Michel mais
effectivement
Bercy
je pense que tous ceux qui ont été
ministres comme moi chacun dans sa
logique et Bercy à sa propre logique de
faire en sorte que les finances
publiques évidemment soit le plus la
plus sain possible mais quand la
décision a été
pris de effectivement mettre fin à cela
ils nous ont proposé de passer les
moyens consacrés à la rénovation
énergétique en supprimant justement le
cite de 1,8 milliards d'euros à 800
millions d'euros alors ça vous montre là
aussi si vous voulez voyez on annonce
des choses on fait un plan honnêtement
le plan que nous avions fait je le dis
parce que c'est très simple travail
collectif donc j'ai pas m'inventer il
était fait sur la méthode était fait sur
les moyens et tout cela mais dans le
même temps
on réduit parce que dès que je suis
arrivé au ministère je permets de le
rappeler nous avions des réunions
régulières pour diminuer les effectifs
pardon de le dire mais quand il faut
faire du diagnostic de performance
énergétique il faut du monde quand il
faut accompagner les citoyens pour
rénover il faut du monde donc dans le
même temps il faut baisser le personnel
dans le même temps on baisse un peu
voilà
après vous évoquiez les changements de
pièces c'est à dire chacun veut
peut-être laisser ça non je pense que
c'est pas ça mais peut-être qu'on a une
tendance à réagir un peu trop vite pour
tu employer une formule en disant le
mieux et l'ennemi du bien voilà parfois
on a peut-être été un peu trop rapide
mais c'est la complexité une espèce de
forêt
d'aide de dans lequel tout le monde se
perdait un tout petit peu et puis je
pense aussi qu'il fallait et ça a été
évoqué il fallait rehausser la barre
c'est-à-dire qu'il fallait pas
simplement
donne des aides pour passer de la
catégorie E à la catégorie D ce qui
s'est très très vite et je pense que
c'est le sujet d'aujourd'hui ce qui
était ce qui devient maintenant évident
c'est qu'il faut rentrer dans des
rénovations globales avec et peut-être
que les aides soient conditionnés à
l'efficacité une fois les travaux
effectués
mais oui quand on a
l'argument était bon de dire on va
passer d'un crédit d'impôt à une prime
parce que chacun avait identifié
effectivement que le crédit d'impôt avec
le report les gens toucher l'argent que
parfois deux ans après alors que et donc
évidemment pour les foyers les plus
modestes c'était difficile donc l'idée
de la prime et après prime rénov elle a
été transformée etc etc moi ce que on en
parlera tout à l'heure si vous me
demandez quels sont les difficultés qui
ont été rentrées à fiabiliser les les
diagnostics de performance énergétique
il y a eu aussi des pénuries de
matériaux faut quand même aussi le le
rappeler moi il me semble d'ailleurs
qu'il y a une filière qui est totalement
sous-exploitée dans la rénovation
thermique c'est les bio-matériaux et on
irait impact à passer avec le monde
agricole sur ce sujet là la complexité
des démarches
pas de feuilles de route opérationnelle
je reviens ce que je disais tout à
l'heure qui déclinerait les objectifs
globaux en termes d'aide de formation
d'artisans et ce année après année
crée le fameux choc de la demande afin
de créer sa marché qui n'existe pas
vraiment pour l'instant je crois que
c'est important comme on l'a fait pour
le solaire par exemple
débloquer des aides importantes c'est
pour ça que tout à l'heure parce qu'il
faut envoyer un signal fort à la filière
je faisais la comparaison entre ce qui a
été fait dans le budget 2023 pour
soutenir le bouquet tarifaire et ce
qu'on donne par ailleurs pour avec la
prime rénov il y a il me semble-t-il une
disproportion bon voilà ce que je
voulais dire pour répondre à votre
question et
que justement vous n'aviez pas en charge
aussi le logement est-ce que ça a été
pour vous une
frein ou une complexité supplémentaire
par rapport à votre responsabilité à
votre mission bon
souvenir je crois qu'après mon départ
les choses ont un peu changé puisque je
crois que le logement est revenu dans le
périmètre donc c'est plutôt une bonne
chose je m'entendais bien avec Monsieur
Mezard alors autant évidemment chacun sa
logique mais donc on n'a pas été en
confrontation comme ça oui en termes
d'organisation de mettre sur une des
mêmes critères des mêmes normes de faire
en sorte que la norme énergétique
devienne une norme sociale parce que je
pense que c'est
important qu'on change d'échelle
évidemment c'est mieux mais vous pouvez
ce n'est pas le propos ici vous pouvez
mettre le ministère de l'Agriculture par
exemple tout le monde en a rêvé en tout
cas certains sous l'autorité du
ministère ça changera pas grand chose
s'il n'y a pas une feuille de route
commune encore une fois que les que les
objectifs soient bien déterminés pour
tout le monde
alors c'est mieux moi je vais au
transport madame borne avec qui on
s'entendait parfaitement etc etc et
c'était mieux effectivement bon ça n'a
pas empêché que on n'a pas réussi à j'ai
vu qu'il y avait une enveloppe qui était
annoncée pour le faire routage qui est
un départ en pauvres du transport de la
politique des transports en France bon
voilà
le ministre
retour d'expérience
je donne une petite anecdote mais parce
qu'elle est symptomatique
moi un jour j'ai demandé qu'est-ce qu'un
ministre peut décider tout seul
non mais c'est important parce que vous
arrivez avec une vision vous arrivez
avec une méthode mais chaque décision
elle est suspendue c'est normal la
Matignon et à Bercy moi je lance un plan
hydrogène j'annonce un budget sur ma
propre budget il a été démenti par une
dépêche alors qu'il était sur mon budget
dans la foulée donc oui cette
organisation cette planification puisque
c'est un mot qui est revenu à la mode il
faut la mettre en oeuvre bien entendu et
pour planifier il faut anticiper mais il
faut coordonner il faut coordonner à
tous les niveaux de de du gouvernement
parce que en réalité la transition
écologique au sens large du terme elle
concerne tous les secteurs et donc le
cas d'école effectivement on a toujours
eu cette confrontation entre le ministre
de l'écologie ministre de l'Agriculture
on était caricatural
tellement c'était voilà sur le long
terme je pense qu'on aurait pu trouver
des points des points de concordance
absolument et des points d'intérêt
commun pour les agriculteurs pour la
transition écologique donc dans le
dispositif voilà actuel tant que le
ministre de l'écologie sera comme ça en
confrontation ou pas en coordination
avec ses collègues alors quelle forme il
faut lui donner je ne vais pas la
suggérer ici moi j'avais plaidé pour un
vice-Premier ministre mais c'est pas le
titre j'étais ministre d'État ça ne m'a
pardon rien apporté en termes de
coordination c'était symbolique pour la
la cause et pour l'objectif
vous voulez rajouter quelque chose
pas sur ce sujet de la tutelle du
logement parce que voilà c'est les
choses se passaient bien mais c'est vrai
que c'est de toute façon compliqué
puisque il faut essayer de coordonner
des positions différentes et que une
mesure qui est bonne pour la rénovation
on nous explique toujours et on le
comprend que ça va ça va freiner la
politique du logement ça va freiner ça
va mettre une norme de plus ça va
augmenter le prix enfin voilà tous ces
arguments là on les connaît on les on
les absorbe aussi et on essaye de
trouver des bonnes décisions le fait que
on soit pas sous le même ministre ça
ralentit un peu les les dispositifs les
discussions etc mais ça résout pas et ça
ne nous a pas en tout cas
particulièrement compliqué la vie mais
par contre pour revenir sur une question
que faisait sur le rapporteur sur
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas fait par
exemple le système de rénovation au
moment de la mutation et qu'on a plutôt
choisi il y a deux solutions
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'elles sont est-ce
que c'est l'une ou l'autre ou est-ce que
c'est l'une et l'autre j'aurais plutôt
tendance moi à mettre une et l'autre
parce que je considère il y a une
priorité à faire avancer tout ça c'est
vrai qu'au moment du Grenelle on avait
travaillé sur les deux les deux pistes
la rénovation à la mutation avec des
systèmes de de de
partir en fait du prix de vente qui
était gardé pour pouvoir financer
les les travaux aussi le vendeur avait
pas fait les travaux lui-même il me
paraissait une solution intelligente
pour notamment les copropriétés parce
qu'au fur et à mesure comme ça que les
les copropriétaires partent on peut
accumuler un peu de fonds pour faire les
travaux quand on peut le faire sinon les
copropriétaires ils sont toujours en
train de partir on n'a jamais les moyens
dont on dont on a besoin pour faire des
travaux ce qui ne veut pas dire que la
solution qu'on a mise en œuvre est pas
intéressante c'est celle de la de la
contrainte cette fois-ci mais sur la
location c'est un autre sujet mais je
pense que les choses sont cumulatives
c'était aussi un sujet qu'on avait
examiné au moment du Grenelle la
difficulté c'est que je Grenelle c'était
il y a longtemps et on avait imaginé des
calendriers très longs avec des des
choses très progressives pour que
justement les travaux et le temps de se
faire et que on ne soit pas en trop
grand nombre avec trop de trop de passe
par thermique et là on est sur des
calendriers plus raccourcis en termes de
mise en oeuvre ce qui rend le sujet
compliqué bien entendu mais sur les
principes on retrouve en fait les mêmes
idées voilà sur au fur et à mesure du
temps avec un questionnement qu'on a eu
également pendant cette période là qui
était de savoir pourquoi enfin est-ce
que c'était bien normal finalement de
mettre en place des dispositifs
identiques sur tout le territoire alors
que selon qu'on est en zone tendue ou en
zone non tendue par exemple
le coût des travaux et la valeur que ça
donne au bien à un sens en zone tendue
et on n'a pas beaucoup en zone non
tendue et donc on met en place des
systèmes d'aide
identiques sur l'ensemble du territoire
alors qu'on est en fait face à des
problèmes différents et avec des besoins
différents de la part des
des personnes on a travaillé sur le
sujet on n'a pas trouvé de solution
simple c'est clair qui a pas de solution
simple mais c'est quand même un sujet je
pense pour essayer de d'utiliser le
mieux possible les crédits qu'on
investit dans cette politique parce
qu'on investit quand même beaucoup
d'argent comme je le disais finalement
on a retrouvé plus ou moins les 2
milliards du cite en bout de course il y
avait on a augmenté les certificats
d'économie d'énergie qui sont une
ressource extrêmement importante pour
ces sujets de rénovation voilà il y a un
certain nombre de d'éléments qui
viennent financer la politique et qui
était
important on va dire est-ce qu'il manque
un milliard ou pas à chaque fois que je
ne sais pas je pense que ça dépend
beaucoup des mesures qu'on met en place
et comme je le disais peut-être pas les
mêmes mesures pour tout le monde au même
endroit bon déjà on a distingué avec ma
prime rénove des des mesures en fonction
du niveau de
revenus des uns des autres ce qui déjà
est un élément important voilà il faut
encore affiner tout ça mais en même
temps comme on le disait peut-être pas
changer trop souvent les règles on a
tellement envie de faire toujours un
petit peu mieux d'avoir l'idée qui va
résoudre les problèmes que finalement le
gain qu'on a et on fait des choses
intelligentes c'est pas un problème mais
le fait ça fait perdre la compréhension
au grand public qui ne nous suit pas sur
toutes nos mesures et qui finit par
parfois ne plus trop savoir ce qu'il
doit faire quand il doit le faire et
pour les professionnels la même chose
donc trouver le déséquilibre moi comme
vous l'avez rappelé c'est un sujet que
je connais depuis longtemps le bon
équilibre entre essayer de faire encore
un petit peu mieux et puis essayer de
pas trop bouger pour que les mesures
avancent réellement je pense qu'il y a
un vrai équilibre compliqué à trouver et
juste pour finir dans les choses qu'on
avait prévues dans le plan
de rénovation énergétique qui nous
paraissait vraiment très importantes
comme la rappeler le ministre d'ailleurs
c'est il faut savoir d'où on part en
matière de rénovation vous devez avoir
le sujet régulièrement on sait jamais
très bien où on en est on sait pas d'où
on part et donc on met un objectif on va
arriver mais on sait pas d'où on part
non on a du mal à savoir si on est
arrivé et pour nous c'était vraiment une
préoccupation d'où
la création d'observatoire
de la rénovation énergétique qui
fonctionne j'ai vu qu'il avait sorti des
chiffres là il y a quelques jours alors
le problème c'est mais c'est pas une
critique de l'Observatoire je sais que
la complexité de la faire c'est que
effectivement on a en 2023 les chiffres
de 2020 et donc toutes les mesures qu'on
a prises entre 2020 et 2023 sur lesquels
vous êtes en train de réfléchir et qu'on
va essayer d'améliorer alors qu'on
n'aura pas encore évalué voilà on est
devant cette contradiction tout le temps
sur ce sujet sur ce sur cette politique
malgré tout il faut et l'Observatoire le
montre on fait des progrès ça fait quand
même de nombreuses années qu'on fait des
investissements sur lesquels il y a des
retours en termes d'efficacité
énergétique
c'est qu'on sait pas bien les mesurer et
on n'est jamais complètement sûr que les
résultats qu'on cherche à obtenir sont
bien ceux qui sont vécus par les gens
puisque les résultats sont encore en
consommation conventionnelle et pas en
constat et quand on sera arrivé à voir
vraiment le des constats de des
consommations on aura déjà fait un gros
progrès pour définir la politique
que finalement on n'arrive pas encore
aujourd'hui à à lever la défiance d'un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens
au regard de ces politiques pour
différentes raisons il y a encore des
cas de freins qui ne sont pas levés et
qui augmentent cette défiance à tel
point que bon nombre de nos concitoyens
renoncent ou en tout cas ne sont se
limite à une rénovation geste par geste
par exemple
vous avez raison d'abord parce que il y
a eu quelques malfaçons il faut le
reconnaître parfois les artisans
eux-mêmes étaient un petit peu dépassés
il faut les reformer pendant
qu'effectivement très longtemps moi j'ai
des exemples autour de moi dans beaucoup
de familles quand on a commencé à dire
aux gens mais c'est le message qui
recevait échanger les portes et fenêtres
ça sert à rien
alors qu'ils avaient déjà investi sur
quelque chose qui leur semblait assez
onéreux donc oui tous ces changements de
pas voilà on crée une forme de défiant
et puis maintenant
on vient leur dire qu'il faut faire une
rénovation globale alors ce qui est
facile dans dans certains bâtiments mais
qui est beaucoup plus compliqué quand
vous êtes dans du haussmanniens quand
vous êtes dans des voilà donc c'est ça
compliqué comme le parc 9 lui se
renouvelle de je crois c'est à peu près
1% par an si on attend que ça soit voilà
il y a une toute petite chose aussi je
voulais ajouter dans dans les verrous
entre guillemets c'est que pour prendre
un exemple
quand il y a eu des dispositifs
législatifs qui ont été votés dans la
loi climat et résilience en 2021 à ce
jour je crois je parle avec prudent je
crois que un quart des de ces
dispositifs n'ont pas encore été
traduits en décret bon ça fait partie
aussi des des petites choses je je
le signale mais bon
après
je crois que c'est très important au
jour d'aujourd'hui de clarifier et pour
ceux qui font le diagnostic et pour les
soeurs ce qu'est une rénovation
performante et comme je le disais là ça
peut pas être simplement un changement
de niveau de basse consommation quoi là
il faut vraiment les plus loin si on
veut durablement protéger
les consommateurs il y a aucune raison
que l'énergie le prix de l'énergie
s'effondre demain
c'est le meilleur bouclier qu'on puisse
leur faire et simultanément pour risque
de me répéter c'est le meilleur service
qu'on puisse rendre pour le pour le pour
le climat quoi voilà donc pour moi
franchement c'est pour le moment la
raison d'être de votre Commission en
matière de transition énergétique c'est
la priorité des priorités et ça a été le
parent pauvre alors l'efficacité la
baisse de la consommation
je le craignais un peu quand il y a eu
cette loi sur la transition énergétique
il y avait l'objectif de réduire la part
du nucléaire il y avait le développement
des renouvelables chacun peut avoir son
avis là-dessus mais quel que soit encore
une fois la stratégie demain on
échappera pas une baisse de consommation
et il faut
me semble-t-il pour l'instant c'est un
peu l'angle mort mais chose espérer que
les travaux de votre commission
permettront justement un éclairage et de
doper cela encore une fois parce qu'il y
a des métiers il y a de l'emploi
et pour avoir visité des logements
sociaux
avec une bonne performance énergétique
je peux vous dire que les gens
ça leur donne un peu de latitude pour
l'alimentaire
merci alors je crois qu'il y avait
Franck Montaugé après Marie-Noël linman
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation vous explications ce qui
est ainsi qu'à vous madame monsieur le
ministre dans votre propos introductif
d'emblée vous avez vous avez indiqué le
manque de méthode et de stratégie
opérationnelle donc pour mener pour
mener l'action du du ministère et vous
avez dit ça aussi de manière de manière
générale vous avez donc posé votre votre
cadre de principe je n'y reviens pas ma
question est la suivante avez-vous
délibérément ou pas
cet usage des cabinets de conseils pour
progresser sur la question de la donc de
la méthode et de la stratégie
opérationnelle de l'action amener et si
oui y a-t-il eu des progrès à partir des
propositions et du travail qui auraient
été réalisées par ces cabinets de
conseils et en particulier sur le sujet
de la rénovation énergétique à mettre à
l'oeuvre et sinon comment cet aspect
donc relatif à la méthode et à la
stratégie de conduite de l'action a-t-il
été traité en interne s'il a été je
suppose que oui puisque vous l'avez posé
comme un problème ou alors c'est vous
avez posé le problème à posteriori après
votre départ
voilà merci
comme c'est une question évidemment
importante j'aurais tendance à répondre
très clairement NON NON de ma mémoire et
de connaissance j'ai aucun souvenir
qu'un cabinet de conseil a été soit
sollicités soit écrit par nos réflexions
sur ce sur ce sujet-là donc la réponse
la réponse est NON et comme c'est
confirmé par ma directrice je n'ai aucun
doute là-dessus alors pour tout vous
dire
dans le je sais pas si vous l'avez eu le
plan d'action sur la rénovation
énergétique a été donc été un des trois
objectifs du Plan Climat que nous avons
sorti
quelques temps après notre arrivée au
gouvernement après moult consultation
parce que je crois que c'est on a pris
quand même le temps il y avait
évidemment
préconisé un suivi alors pas simplement
par le cabinet du ministère par y
compris par l'ADEME y compris par nos
propres directions etc etc sauf qu'on
n'a pas eu le temps puisque là pour le
coup on est parti un petit peu
précipitamment n'a pas eu le temps de
mettre en place là
et c'est vrai que quand il y a un
passage de ministres à ministres bon je
l'ai moi-même vécu
il n'y a pas ce qu'on appellerait dans
un autre domaine un espèce de tuilage
qui permettrait de dire bon voilà
c'est un peu ce sentiment de l'accès de
continuité qui est encore une fois sur
ces objectifs de temps long il y a des
choses sur lequel on devrait être garant
de parce qu'il y a des lois et nous
sommes censés les uns et des autres
mettre en place ces lois je peux vous
citer un nombre de d'objectifs dans la
loi et les lois dont on parle tout à
l'heure qui sont qui restent des paroles
vaines donc quelque part nous sommes
hors la loi entre guillemets mais après
pour pas non plus éluder votre question
je mets cette question sur la table sans
avoir forcément est-ce que notre
vigilance si on avait duré si on était
resté jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
est-ce qu'elle aurait suffi
je serai prétentieux de vous dire oui
parce que il aurait fallu un moment ou
un autre revoir le budget là combien de
fois je me rappelle sur les aides à
l'achat d'automobile propre tout d'un
coup en plein été on nous dit on va
mettre fin à cette ce soutien alors que
les garagistes en avaient fait l'avance
etc etc donc il y avait aussi sur cet
important il y a besoin aussi et qu'à
Bercy les choses soient suivies et que
l'engagement soit pas simplement
l'engagement d'un ministère mais
l'engagement de l'État
voilà mais c'est la question centrale à
qui peut-on confier cet évaluation que
ce suivi ce monitoring et comment
peut-on le rendre justement vraiment
irréversible et efficient
je suis désolé de t'amener la question
et pas forcément la réponse détaillée
mais je suis c'est ma conviction à
l'observation encore une fois je je
pardonne reprendre l'idée de l'objectif
de réduction des pesticides pourquoi
a-t-on attendu l'échéance de l'objectif
pour s'apercevoir qu'on était en dessous
même pas en dessous c'est même pas qu'on
était allait pas éteint
c'est qu'on avait continué voilà
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre les deux
donc ça c'est un déficit nos démocratie
c'est parce que encore une fois on est
dans ces échanges de temps long avec des
mutations qui sont complexes et qui fait
pas de dire aux agriculteurs voilà il
faut regarder souvent quand on prend une
décision
pardon je reviens aux pesticides mais
parce que c'est un bon exemple
c'est bien de dire on va se passer je
sais pas moi du glyphosate où on va se
passer de mais faut peut-être quand même
le lendemain évaluer s'il y a des
alternatives est-ce que ce travail est
fait voir où sont les impasses parce que
il y a des modes de production vous
pouvez vous passer de telle substance de
votre part est-ce que vous mobilisez
l'INRA pour regarder s'il y a
des solutions autre j'ai pas vraiment le
sentiment voilà c'est à dire que on a le
on a on pense que les objectifs parce
qu'ils sont là ils vont s'auto-réaliser
en réalité non ils sauteralise pas et le
travail il est après voilà et ce travail
là n'est pas effectué enfin
je donne ça avec beaucoup de prudence
mais c'était mon sentiment voilà on se
débarrasse de quelque chose parce qu'on
avait conscience que c'était important
qu'il y avait une demande sociétaire etc
on faisait un plan vous avez une
conférence de presse
vraiment le plan de rénovation le
l'autre franchement je l'ai relu là
depuis que je savais que j'allais
teditionner il est remarquable enfin
voilà je le dis d'autant plus mais bon
une fois qu'il est là il faut le mettre
en oeuvre et il faut les moyens adaptés
tu as un bémol
enfin je pense que sur cette politique
plus que sur d'autres il y a quand même
une certaine continuité ne serait-ce que
parce qu'il y a quand même des outils
comme l'ADEM il travaille sur ce sujet
depuis des années et qui petit à petit
amen des éléments fait la base de
l'information et puis l'administration
aussi bien entendu et puis maintenant la
nappe puisque Lana est très mobilisée
dans ce secteur donc pour répondre à
votre question on a effectivement comme
les administres pas du tout travaillé
avec des cabinets ni sur ça ni sur autre
chose d'ailleurs
le sujet
de la de la rénovation a priori c'était
un sujet que je connaissais bien donc
moi j'étais très mobilisé sur le sujet
et donc pour travailler avec les équipes
directement avec l'administration etc ça
s'est passé très facilement on a d'abord
fait le Plan Climat c'était l'urgence
dans le Plan Climat il y avait priorité
nationale à la rénovation donc on a fait
le plan sur adovation c'était la méthode
bon après effectivement ça encore de
route mais en tout cas jusque là il y
avait de la continuité il y avait quand
même beaucoup de continuité heureusement
dans ce qu'on écrivait dans le plan de
rénovation même si je vous rappelle
qu'il y avait des choses dans le
programme du président puisque la
création de la transformation du crédit
d'impôt en prime c'était écrit dans le
gouvernement donc voilà on était pas
forcément complètement convaincu que
c'était l'urgence mais il y avait des
choses à faire la disparition du crédit
d'impôt bon c'était peut-être un peu
rapide donc d'ailleurs ça s'est fait
plus doucement que que ce qui était
prévu donc sur tout ça je trouve que il
y a plutôt eu un effort de continuité le
fait si on prend le le cas du cite
portée fenêtre bon bah effectivement il
y a vraiment on s'apercevait que on
dépensait beaucoup d'argent pour pour se
porter fenêtres et que ça faisait
augmenter les travaux des portes et
fenêtres ça c'est sûr mais pas forcément
on réduire les améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique bon après qu'est-ce qu'on
faisait de c'était une autre question
mais sur le principe on était plutôt
dans quelque chose qui allait dans le
même sens que précédemment je prends un
autre sujet vous avez beaucoup sur les
logements mais sur le décret tertiaire
par exemple
voilà ça faisait des années qu'on
essayait que l'administration essayait
de faire passer un décrétaire qui se
faisait retoquer régulièrement par le
Conseil d'État et par les tribunaux on a
continué pour montrer la continuation la
continuité on a continué à travailler
sur ce sujet on a fini par sortir ce
fameux décrétaire donc nous la relancé
il est sorti quelques temps quelques
temps plus tard il est en cours
d'application voilà je trouve que
même si il y a beaucoup de retard sur
les choses qui ont été annoncées elles
finissent par arriver le problème c'est
qu'elles arrivent avec beaucoup de
retard et qu'ensuite on met des
calendriers trop courts pour les pour
les appliquer mais
si vous regardez les outils qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui
le les certificats d'économie d'énergie
le DPE
la formation des professionnels tout ça
ce sont des choses qui ont été lancées
je sais bien parce que j'étais à l'ADEME
en 2005 2006
ce sont les fondements de nos politiques
d'aujourd'hui alors on ajoute un peu on
enlève on essaye de tout plus efficace
bien entendu mais il y a quand même des
choses qui qui perdurent n'a pas encore
trouvé toute la toutes les solutions et
vous posiez la question monsieur le
rapporteur mais pourquoi malgré le fait
que tout ça a l'air d'aller dans le bon
sens pour qu'on y arrive pas et parce
que c'est très complexe et que quand on
a un élément qui flèche qui flanche et
vous l'avez dit la confiance c'est le
cœur du sujet parce que c'est quand même
on attend quand même qui est 60 millions
de Français qui fassent quelque chose
bon pas 60 millions parce qu'il y a les
enfants mais on va million de ménages
qui agissent c'est c'est c'est énorme
quoi comme décision et qui agissent pas
de manière marginale qui fasse des
travaux chez eux et quand on fait des
travaux chez soi on voit ce que ça
signifie en terme de coût certes mais
aussi de complexité d'ennuis de
résultats qui sont pas au rendez-vous et
tout ça les gens le savent très bien
donc on est sur une matière extrêmement
humaine qu'on travaille avec des choses
un peu technocratiques je reconnais et
qui avance progressivement ce qui nous
manque je pense vraiment parce que je
pense que ça nous rassurera un peu tous
c'est une mesurer les gains qu'on a fait
parce que si la consommation d'énergie
et notamment d'électricité française
plafonne ou à même eu tendance à
diminuer je compte pas cette année qui
est un peu particulière mais depuis une
dizaine d'années alors que il y a plus
de logements il y a plus de gens dans de
personnes voilà et de la démographie
augmente c'est bien qu'on a fait des
gains d'efficacité on a on a fait des
gains on n'est pas capable de les
mesurer mais ils existent alors est-ce
qu'on les a fait au bon coup l'euro au
kilowatt-heure économisé ça par contre
il faudrait regarder d'un peu plus près
mais voilà rassurons-nous quand même un
peu par le fait que il se passe des
choses et que les Français font des
choses pour pour améliorer leur logement
ils le font d'autant plus que l'énergie
est en chèvre ils sont incités vraiment
à les faire
Marie-Noël linman oui monsieur mindis
moi je partage complètement votre
diagnostic sur le fait que c'est d'abord
une question de méthode et je crois que
vous avez ciblé les quatre cibles qui
devraient être notre feuille de route ne
croyez-vous pas qu'une un des outils
qu'on pourrait essayer de promouvoir
c'est l'idée d'une loi de programmation
plurienne
sur six ans par exemple la durée d'un
mandat parce que
l'argument du temps long s'entend mais
il sert aussi à se défausser toujours de
c'est en fin de course que les
contraintes devront être levées et une
loi de programmation elle doit
travailler sur bien sûr ce qu'on peut
faire tout de suite mais comment ça
engage comme vous l'aviez dit Madame
comment ça engage les mutations pour
l'avenir la deuxième chose c'est que
dans mon ressenti depuis longtemps sur
ces sujets
c'est qu'on ne commence pas par le plus
facile je veux pas dire le moins coûteux
je parle le plus facile le plus facile
c'est quand même les bâtiments publics
les écoles les hôpitaux
on pourrait très bien programmer sur 6
ans pas toutes les écoles peut-être mais
x collège x lycée X
et que les collectivités et l'État qui
travaillent en commun doivent définir le
cas de financier qui permet d'attendre
ses objectifs dans le logement c'est sûr
que la confrontation entre le
particulier alors propriétaire ou
locataire etc et bien plus complexe
qu'avec les bailleurs sociaux si avec
les bailleurs sociaux ont signé un
accord précis sur comment on va vous les
financer combien vous en faites chaque
année sur quel territoire comment et où
chacun s'engage tiens il s'agit pas
d'aller signer des trucs en disant on va
faire plaisir au gouvernement mais après
et si par ailleurs on met en place comme
jadis puisqu'on revient à la
planification dans la planification
générale de Gaulle tout n'était pas à
jeter il y avait en particulier dans les
groupes du plan des groupes de suivi je
me rappelle tout au début
une amie le vieillissement de la
population s'adapte mais bon il y avait
les premières maisons de retraite et
tout ça ça a été planifié entre
guillemets et c'était pas on va pas
refaire de la même manière mais il y
avait des groupes de suivi au plan qui
eux regardaient qui n'étaient ni du
ministère de schmolduc et autres qui eux
regardaient pourquoi ça marchait
pourquoi ça marchait pas et qui pouvait
être un regard justement d'évaluation
active des politiques mises en oeuvre
j'ajoute à cela que nous sommes dans une
France décentralisée c'est pas au Sénat
qu'on va vous dire l'inverse
où il faut trouver une nouvelle
articulation entre l'engagement de
l'État et ce que les collectivités
locales sont prêtes ou penses le plus
intelligent à faire chez eux et c'est
pas elles n'ont pas toujours tort elles
peuvent l'avoir quand elle veut pas
construire le logement sociaux elles
sont tort mais néanmoins
il y avait ce qu'on appelait les
contrats plans pourquoi une loi de
programmation ne pourrait pas être
adoucée à des contrats d'objectifs avec
les collectivités locales Région
Département agglo même des communes avec
ou chacun dit voilà moi ce que je pense
qu'on peut faire dans les six ans
comment on fait une filière chez nous de
laine comment on fait etc et un truc
très opérationnel avec par ailleurs
l'obligation tous les deux ans chaque
collectivité délibère pour dire voilà ce
qu'on a fait voilà ce qui reste à faire
voilà ce qu'on pourra pas faire parce
que c'est vraiment c'était trompé moi je
crois que cette mobilisation collective
autour d'une loi de programmation d'une
vision de la planification mais qui ne
renvoie pas pétaouch donc les oies les
objectifs concrets qu'on doit mettre en
oeuvre tout de suite serait à mon avis
au moins progrès au regard de ce que
nous avons engagé jusqu'à présent
non mais je ne peux voilà je peux que
caderer bien entendu on fait une
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
c'est bien c'est bien dans cette cet
esprit là ce qu'il y a c'est que il faut
des points d'étape aussi voilà et qui
sont importants et que ces points
d'étape soit aussi
contraignant entre guillemets faut de la
norme aussi je sais que c'est un gros
mot mais il en faut voilà mais la norme
pas brutale bien entendu
non non voilà je
ce mot de planification moi quand j'ai
vu revenir le Commissariat au Plan
j'ai revu je l'ai vu revenir c'est pas
un critique avec un certain espoir parce
que on peut on peut entendre le mot
planification sous d'un mauvais jour
mais je pense qu'au contraire cette
planification pour qu'elle soit juste et
pour qu'elle soit performante il faut
l'organiser il faut la planifier je me
répète mais c'est tellement important je
pense nous démocratie notre démocratie
comme les autres ont été un petit peu
pris de cours par cette intrusion du
long terme dans notre logiciel et qu'on
est un petit peu démuni c'est normal et
là on doit être dans le prospectif on
doit être donc c'est pour ça que c'est
ce sujet pour moi prépondérant parce que
d'entendre parfois comme ça de toute
façon la politique ça sert à rien ou les
promesses n'engagent que ce ok très bien
on peut trouver mais
voilà quand on est à l'exercice d'une
responsabilité on a envie d'abord on a
envie que ça fonctionne on a envie de
laisser une trace on a envie voilà et si
on ne le fait pas quelques fois c'est
que peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose
qui fonctionne pas dans notre mise en
oeuvre voilà donc je pense
qu'effectivement les outils dont vous
parlez sont pour moi très important
alors Sabine dragsler merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors moi je m'intéresse
beaucoup au patrimoine et en particulier
au patrimoine non protégé c'est à dire
les maisons de novillages et en fait je
suis très inquiète et je ne suis pas la
seule à l'être parce qu'on se rencontre
que qu'actuellement avec le DPE et
surtout avec les préconisations qui sont
faites avec le DPE on risque d'aller
vers un saccage patrimonial parce qu'en
fait c'est préconisations sont les mêmes
quel que soit le type de bâti et en fait
il n'y a pas du tout de on ne prend pas
en compte on va dire les particularités
du du bâti ancien et on demande en fait
au actuellement propriétaire bailleur
s'ils veulent continuer à louer leur
bien de l'isoler avec des gestes et des
matériaux qui sont complètement
inadaptés qui vont provoquer des
altérations qui vont être définitives et
je le vois parce que j'habite en Alsace
et que chez moi déjà on met du
polystyrène sur du de bois qui vont
faire pourrir les maisons et qui vont
être démolis puisque avec le zan on va
chercher du terrain maintenant voilà
vous allez avoir des maisons inhabitées
qui vont se détériorer des maisons
anciennes qu'on va démolir et voilà donc
en fait je j'aurais aimé savoir si en
fait lorsque vous étiez ministre vous
travaillez avec le ministère de la
Culture qui a quand même comme mission
de protéger le patrimoine et quel que
soit le type de patrimoine est-ce qu'il
y avait un travail voilà un terme
ministériel sur ces questions là est-ce
que est-ce qu'il a été tenu compte on va
dire des des propriétés de ce type de
bâti en tirant profit par exemple des
recherches du Serena puisqu'on s'est
quand même depuis 2011 que voilà on
s'est beaucoup de choses sur les
particularités de ce type de bâti et
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a eu
aussi un travail avec par exemple le
ministère de l'agriculture sur justement
des techniques on va dire qui seraient
plus respectueuses plus écologique
d'isolation moins destructrice aussi et
est-ce qu'on a réfléchi par exemple à un
système de déco conditionnalité des
aides
voilà merci
alors la de mémoire
je ne pense pas qu'on a pu aboutir à une
concertation avec le mystère de la
culture en revanche moi j'étais très
demandeur mais je n'ai pas eu le temps
de mettre en œuvre mais c'est quelque
part ça dépend du ministère de la
Culture une réflexion globale avec les
bâtiments de France parce que
effectivement sur ce le patrimoine dont
vous me parlez on arrive à une
difficulté c'est qu'on peut pas saccager
au nom de cette obligation notre
patrimoine qui soit particulier ou que
ça soit les bâtiments publics c'est vrai
que si on vous préconise une isolation
par l'extérieur d'une maison à colombage
pour me prendre que cet exemple là c'est
un peu un saccage donc je pense qu'il
faut là il y avait la réflexion n'était
pas aboutie mais elle méritait d'être
lancé parce que ça concerne une partie
de évidemment du bâti en France mais là
il fallait effectivement essayer de voir
s'il y avait des alternatives pour ça
que tout à l'heure je me suis permis de
parler des matériaux biosourcés parce
que je pense que là franchement
économiquement techniquement il y a une
partie de la solution voilà donc il
fallait probablement avoir une certaine
souplesse et c'est ça aussi dans la
progressivité c'est que l'identifier ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il y a des
choses où c'est possible et il y a des
choses ou des évidence il y a pas besoin
d'être grand sorciers pour dire bah là
c'est très sympa mais voilà donc il
fallait aussi peut-être faire travailler
un certain nombre d'acteurs pour voir
les alternatives qui étaient qui étaient
proposées c'est clair que c'est vrai
aussi sur le les énergies renouvelables
bon ben on n'a pas envie de mettre une
éolienne sur Notre-Dame ou un panneau
solaire sur le fort de je ne sais quoi
voilà donc après dans dans cette
mutation là évidemment il faut avoir un
petit peu de
pardon de dire mais un peu
d'intelligence pour ne pas sacrifier une
cause pour pour l'autre mais nous
n'avons pas eu le temps les plus loin
moi j'étais très preneur de et notamment
de travailler avec les architectes parce
que
ces sujets là pour beaucoup
d'architectes sont des sujets qui leur
sont totalement étrangers il fallait pas
abandonner la beauté des choses pour
l'efficacité il me semble pas quelque
chose de forcément qu'il ne soit pas
solutionnable
merci madame la Présidente le ministre
vous avez fait état de ce mot qui qui
sans doute en partage largement partagé
le mot social et il y a effectivement
dans ces politiques qui a une
acceptabilité aussi
et puis une on le voit bien aujourd'hui
une précarité en matière énergétique qui
est croissante donc se baser sur les
données de la consommation
récente n'aurait pas grand sens puisque
bon nombre de nos concitoyens ont fait
des efforts de sobriété à l'appel
d'ailleurs du gouvernement eu égard à la
crise que nous connaissons avec la
guerre en Ukraine mais au-delà de ça on
vient d'entendre Marie-Noël Lindeman
pointer du doigt dans la planification
ce qui pourrait être un effet levier
c'est l'ensemble des bâtiments publics y
a-t-il eu à l'époque déjà parce que moi
bien aimé aussi le fait que on rappelle
qu'un certain nombre de fondamentaux
parce que les fondamentaux n'ont pas
bougé depuis mais ont déjà été posées
dans les années 2005-2006 donc on voit
bien qu'il y a un porté à connaissance
sur lequel tout le monde s'accorde on
voit bien et elle rapporte la rappeler
tout à l'heure qui avait une forme de
d'unanimité très transpartisanes sur le
sujet et donc on en revient à un souci
de méthodologie est-ce que pour être
efficace il n'y a pas lieu d'avoir
quelque chose d'incitatif de de très
fort à l'égard des bâtiments publics
quel qu'en soit le propriétaire que ce
soit l'état direct ou les collectivités
et donc que pensez-vous de cette
question puisque les contrats de plan
est à région vont être en négociation
sous peu on va aborder bien sûr le
problème des mobilités je partage aussi
ce que vous disiez sur le fer out il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin et
beaucoup plus vite
sur sur cette question là mais est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que la clé peut
se situer dans ce dialogue entre l'État
et les territoires et notamment parce
que ils en ont la compétence en matière
de on a évoqué le 0 artificialisation
nette
les intercommunalités ont une compétence
en matière de pluie elles ont une
compétence en matière de PLA et donc là
aussi sur les questions liées aux
offices HLM au logement social je pense
que là on doit trouver les bons
interlocuteurs pour dire de se fixer des
objectifs
atteignables crédible atteignable avec
un calendrier qui soit plus facile à
respecter
pardon c'est un peu comme avec
Marie-Noëlle lenmann j'adhère
effectivement à ce que vous dites
d'abord c'est déjà le cas parfois il y a
d'abord il y a des territoires et des
régions qui sont très offensifs sur ces
sujets là il y en a qui ont pris du
retard d'autres pas
c'est pas là où l'autre c'est à dire que
évidemment la priorité pour des raisons
sociales qu'on a évité qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est d'essayer d'enrayer
cette précarité énergétique pour les
ménages les plus modestes mais si on
regarde les objectifs globaux qui sont
les outils climatiques notamment
évidemment il faut que on ne baisse pas
la garde sur le tertiaire
et sur les bâtiments publics bon bien
entendu donc oui je pense que là les
régions et l'État ils ont un travail en
commun à faire
moi je crois beaucoup l'outil de la
alors je fais une petite parenthèse mais
la fiscalité qu'on le veuille ou pas
c'est quand même aussi un bon outil dès
lors qu'il y a la fiscalité incitative
et la fiscalité dissuasive et que les
deux aussi sont progressifs voilà
et je pense que il en vaut des bâtiments
publics comme des
bâtiments de particuliers il faut
d'abord qu'on clarifie la définition
d'une rénovation performante moi
j'insiste là-dessus et pour moi il faut
une nette qui soit indexée sur la
performance après travaux c'est ça qui
est important faut mettre la barre haut
parce que encore une fois l'objectif il
est il est pas mince il est il est il
est important Michel
sur le sujet des bâtiments publics vous
avez tout à fait raison ça fait des
années et des années que le sujet est
sur la table que dans le cadre des
programmes état exemplaires et autres
choses de gens là on a considéré
qu'effectivement puisqu'on demandait aux
Français de faire des efforts sur
efficacités de leur de leur logement
c'est normal que les personnes publiques
état et collectivités face des choses
bon nous quand on est arrivé clairement
vous savez bien que non c'était pas le
cas parce que c'est des moyens
financiers dont les services sont
toujours besoin et donc c'est ce qui
vient après surtout qu'on Prusse on a
toujours un problème qui tient en fait
que j'avais on avait essayé de mettre
des choses en place dans le cadre d'un
des programmes est à exemplaires c'est
que
l'économie que vous allez faire en
faisant donc en mettant vos crédits pour
faire des travaux et crédits c'est des
crédit tout ce qu'il y a de plus normaux
vous allez faire des économies de
fonctionnement mais l'économie de
fonctionnement elle va passer à Bercy
donc voilà il y a un vrai sujet de quand
vous êtes l'état collectivité c'est un
peu la même chose mais bon vous êtes
l'État c'est clairement ça donc on avait
essayé de mettre en place des systèmes
dans lequel une partie de l'économie
restait dans le budget voilà ça a duré
un an et demi ça a marché mais après ça
s'est arrêté parce que voilà ça marchait
résultat sur les bâtiments publics il y
a effectivement un énorme travail à
faire donc beaucoup d'argent à mettre et
quand on
est arrivé ça faisait partie des
éléments du grand plan d'investissement
dont on parlait le ministre tout à
l'heure avec voilà des travaux qu'il
fallait faire de manière systématique
avec la des préfets etc donc je sais pas
très bien on en est aujourd'hui mais ça
fait partie vraiment des sujets sur
lesquels il y a tout de suite des tas de
choses à faire en y intégrant puisqu'on
est en train de faire des rénovations
l'adaptation au changement climatique
parce que on va pas faire d'abord de
l'innovation et après l'adaptation
puisque ça on le fera pas de choix et
que les sujets sont sont pour beaucoup
se croisent et donc ce sera important de
travailler sur les deux sujets en même
temps sur les les
HLM et les logements social d'une
manière générale c'est pas l'endroit où
on a le plus de difficultés parce que
justement comme c'est plus facile vous
le savez bien Madame la Ministre on a
mis en place très régulièrement des
alors bon il en reste toujours un des
passeurs thermiques
mais il y en a c'est quand même
l'endroit où finalement en pourcentage
par rapport à l'ensemble de du parc
français c'est là où il y en a le moins
faire encore bien sûr quelques efforts
pour qu'il y en ait plus du tout
le réparateur
et une dernière une dernière question
peut-être cette réflexion par rapport à
ce que vous avez dit sur la sur la
fiscalité et je trouve qui est
importante et c'est vrai que vous avez
été à la période des gilets jaunes
savoir si quelque part il y a pas un
regret en fait sur sur cette période
puisque bon j'ai pas interpréter le
mouvement de plein de manières
différentes mais en tout cas il y avait
la question de la taxe carbone et de la
taxation de de l'énergie fossile et que
en soi était pas forcément une mauvaise
idée en tout cas de pouvoir justement
taxer ces énergies fossiles mais
peut-être ce qui a manqué c'est c'est la
réorientation et tout le discours et
tout ce qu'on pouvait raconter derrière
et notamment en lien avec la rénovation
thermique je trouvais que c'était
quelque chose qui était particulièrement
intéressant c'est à dire que de financer
par exemple un reste à charge zéro via
justement cette taxe en tout cas avoir
quelque chose qui soit beaucoup plus
lisible avec des retombées très claires
en fait sur le pourquoi en taxe d'un
côté mais à quoi ça sert et comment
justement on met en place cette
transition et donc est-ce que derrière
ça il y a pas un petit un petit regret
en tout cas sur cette période et sur ce
qui aurait peut-être dû ce qu'on aurait
pu être dû faire
oui
un regret oui parce que
j'ai enfin
essayé d'organiser une réflexion globale
avec notamment Bercy pendant que j'étais
au gouvernement sur la fiscalité
écologique parce que on traite toujours
la fiscalité écologique à part de la
fiscalité donc c'est toujours une
fiscalité additionnelle
et souvent fiscalité dissuasives et
punitive pour dire les choses plutôt
qu'une fiscalité incitative et
j'ai tendance à penser qu'il faut pas
taxer ce qui peut l'être aussi ce qui
doit l'être bon et que la fiscalité
peut-être à mon levier et elle est
d'ailleurs elle donne des signaux pour
les consommateurs comme pour les
producteurs encore faut-il que si vous
mettez en place de la fiscalité
dissuasive ou incitative il faut que ça
soit aussi progressif et là il y a eu je
le dis évidemment
j'ai eu le sentiment que cette taxe
carbone que je défendais depuis
longtemps
on trouvait là une occasion de
plus les dire améliorer les recettes de
l'État sur le dos de l'écologie
et je pense que ça a été fait un peu
brutalement voilà pour dire les choses
calmement surtout quand ça s'est fait
simultanément avec il était important de
faire en sorte d'organiser le rattrapage
entre le coût du diesel et le coût de
l'essence normal parce que c'était pas
normal compte tenu
de la réalité scientifique que le diesel
bénéficie à long terme de cette avantage
fiscal mais pas dans cette brutalité et
là aussi quand avec les principes dont
je parlais tout à l'heure il faut
identifier pendant très longtemps on a
incité des gens à acheter des véhicules
diesel souvent ce sont des ménages qui
sont dans des situations où il y a pas
de transport en commun donc c'était la
triple Pen donnait le signal c'est
important parce que vous avez vu
d'ailleurs comme le marché à hobby et
mais ça a été me semble-t-il fait dans
une trop grande brutalité et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'à terme j'espère que pour un
jour avoir une réflexion globale sur la
fiscalité et pas simplement encore une
fois une réflexion aléatoire sur la
fiscalité écologique et pour moi c'est
un outil très important
et voilà donc
j'adhère aussi à ce que est-ce que vous
dites et j'ai eu mon regret c'est que
j'ai eu ce petit sentiment que
c'est pas qu'on m'emprunter une idée
parce qu'elle n'était pas de moi
c'est une évidemment une
décision enfin une préconisation
d'économistes prestigieux depuis très
longtemps bien entendu de donner un prix
au carbone mais que là tout d'un coup on
trouvait une occasion une opportunité et
je suis pas sûr que l'objectif
écologique était le voilà mais je dis ça
avec beaucoup de prudence mais on a vu
le résultat c'était évidemment dans un
moment où on enlevait on enlevait
certaines aides
c'est insupportable voilà
et encore une fois c'est ça c'est de
l'accompagnement c'est identifier c'est
dire attention sur un échéancier bon ben
il va y avoir un rattrapage du prix mais
peut-être que le rattrapage plutôt
d'augmenter simplement le diesel il
arrêtait aussi peut-être de baisser un
peu l'autre voilà de le faire d'une
manière beaucoup plus progressive la
brutalité
était évidemment fonctionne pas et c'est
l'histoire
on est plein d'exemples
et bien écoutez on vous remercie oui
bien sûr parce que
je sais que vous avez reçu Esther Duflot
et je sais qu'elle préconise et j'ai vu
de si de là un débat en disant ce que
préconise Esther Duflot en fait c'est
beaucoup plus intelligent et efficace
que le reste alors nous on adhère
totalement évidemment
à ce que préconise Esther Duflot en y
ajoutant une petite chose c'est que
c'est pas ça ou autre chose c'est ça et
autre chose voilà quand on
était au gouvernement en effet avec
Michel fait faire un rapport sur ce
sujet justement de l'individu
individualisation des des frais de
chauffage pour pouvoir confins
convaincre de l'efficacité de ces
dispositifs j'ai fait avec l'ADEME le
gars immédiat
c'était 10% à peu près mais voilà ce
type d'action et il n'est pas possible
dans tous les immeubles en copropriété
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
savoir mais je voulais le dire parce que
je pense qu'effectivement ça peut être
très efficace mais il faut pas le faire
au détriment d'autre chose quoi voilà
merci de cette précision merci de vos
être soumis à cette audition et on vous
remercie on vous souhaite une bonne
soirée monsieur le ministre et Madame la
Directrice la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur et madame monsieur